san isidro entre méxico y eeuu es el
punto fronterizo más frecuentado del
mundo entre los viajeros cargados de
maletas ucranianos o rusos buscan
refugiarse en eeuu
platini y su familia abandonaron ucrania
el 24 de febrero primer día de la guerra
acabamos de llegar a méxico
hemos viajado más de 11 mil kilómetros
en avión
todo en él
[Música]
me siento muy cansado y nervioso estoy
triste por la guerra en ucrania la
familia viajó durante 20 días y cruzo 6
países de europa después de una salida
precipitada
no fue fácil
lloramos mucho
en nuestra ciudad bombardearon los
aeropuertos los bomberos
esta guerra ya ha llevado más de 45
millones de ucranianos al exilio
principalmente hacia los países
limítrofes pero cada vez son más los que
recorren 10.000 kilómetros para llegar
hasta tijuana
anastasia hasta con su marido
estadounidense
abandonó su ciudad hardcore unos días
antes del comienzo de la ofensiva rusa
bombardearon mi casa bombardearon la
casa de mi abuela
después de unas horas de espera los
guardias estadounidenses le indican al
grupo que puede pasar a diferencia de
los ucranianos la mayoría de los
solicitantes de asilo no tendrán esta
oportunidad maciá artiem y su hijo
llegaron desde rusia
buscamos asilo político en eeuu
[Música]
somos protestantes trabajamos para la
iglesia estadounidense
[Música]
nos oprimen y nos consideran unos
agentes de octubre
américa
para ellos es imposible cruzar la
frontera a causa del título 42 esta
disposición impide que los migrantes
presenten una solicitud de asilo en
territorio estadounidense una medida que
se adoptó hace dos años para evitar la
propagación del cobi 19 aunque los
ucranianos son admitidos en eeuu por
razones humanitarias cada vez más rusos
quedan varados en tijuana es el caso de
agatha y su familia llegaron a méxico
hace más de dos semanas
que nunca había visto antes y todo esto
me parece horrible
todos esos cercos con alambres de
lenguas parecen tan fríos impiden que
las personas huyan de lo que tienen que
huir
de lo que es simplemente
cercanos al líder de oposición alexéi
navalni la familia prefirió abandonar el
país ante el endurecimiento de las
represiones
desde que empezó la guerra en ucrania la
situación política en rusia se ha
deteriorado
incluso después de irán de renunciar
empatiza con esto
se aprobó una ley que prevén hasta 15
años de cárcel para las personas que
llamen a este conflicto una guerra
las asociaciones de ayuda a los
migrantes denuncian la injusticia del
título 42
y
también riesgo la vida de las personas
les niega su derecho a protección
internacional y al estar todos varados
aquí en la frontera estamos hablando de
miles de familias
en ciudades tan peligrosas como tijuana
ciudad juárez reynosa están expuestos a
muchísimos peligros también méxico no es
un tercer país seguro desde hace mucho
tiempo tijuana encarna las esperanzas
perdidas de miles de emigrantes en la
casa del migrante hondureño salvadoreños
haitianos o mexicanos esperan con
impaciencia poder presentar su solicitud
de asilo y quien está alojado aquí desde
hace tres meses y quisiera que la
solidaridad con los ucranianos se
extendiera a los demás
es bueno que los acojan pero no hay que
olvidarse los haitianos ni de los otros
que no pueden volver a su país por
problemas políticos
política
desde que se estableció bajo donald
trump el título 42 ha causado la
expulsión de más de 17 millones de
personas